hi mystery Recaps here today I'm going
to explain a South Korean disaster
action comedy film called exit spoilers
ahead watch out and take care
Lee Yong Nam is a man in his early 30s
who still lives with his parents back in
his college days he was the leader of
the climbing group and had won Gold in
several tournaments however now finding
a job with this qualification has become
a challenge no matter where he applies
he is always rejected yangnam spends
most of his days in the park practicing
parkour and acrobatics he thinks it is
cool but the whole town regards him as a
loser even his own nephew doesn't want
to be around him at home things are even
worse young nem is treated like a kid by
his parents and his elder sister alike
although they love him a lot they never
miss an opportunity to scold him yangnam
is heavily dependent on them too despite
being a grown man his mother still makes
his hair one day the family decides to
celebrate his mom's 70th birthday since
their house is too small to host a party
Yong Nam is tasked with finding a venue
without thinking twice he immediately
suggests the cloud Garden a three-star
hotel located in the city this is
because
College crash and fellow climbing member
weeju works there as the vice manager
the two used to be good friends back
then but it has been five years since
they last spoke nothing makes you look
hotter than rolling up saying hey it's
my mom's birthday in the next scene
yangnam and his family get dressed and
head to the venue once they reach it
yangnam is swarmed by his distant family
members who mostly bombard him with
uncomfortable questions about his work
life they also inquire if he has a
girlfriend but young Nam simply ignores
them after a while as the cake-cutting
ceremony is about to begin young Nam
finally sees his Crush Ouija when she
notices him he pretends to be shocked
later the two head to a silent area
where weju expresses her happiness to
see him again she inquires if he knew
that she was working here but yangnam
calls it a coincidence according to him
he selected the place because of its
good reviews on Google despite being
over an hour drive away when asked about
what he does for a living young Nam lies
saying that he is the manager of a
multi-million dollar company shortly
after Ouija is called by her manager Mr
Goo who at first Praises her for her
excellent work but then he starts
hitting on her weiju is unsure of how to
get rid of him because the hotel belongs
to his father if she rejects him she
will probably get fired elsewhere a
large truck pulls up in the most crowded
part of the city the driver then gets
out and opens several valves which
releases a mysterious gas in large
amounts unfortunately the gas turns out
to be poisonous and it starts affecting
the people nearby soon hundreds of
people start collapsing on the ground
and some even die on the spot when
people try to flee the area deadly Road
accidents ensue turning the city into
utter Bedlam meanwhile the people in
Cloud Garden are still oblivious to
whatever is happening outside they are
seen dancing and celebrating with all
their energy giving Mom piggybacks and
stuff suddenly a nearby accident
launches a glass cylinder inside which
startles young Nam and the others as
they rush outside to check they see the
thick layer of gas approaching their way
hundreds and thousands of people are
fleeing the scene making them realize
that something deadly is coming hence
Ouija hurriedly escorts everyone inside
the hotel while everyone obliges young
Nam decides to stay as his sister has
just arrived in her car he screams at
her to get out immediately but by the
time she realizes what's happening it is
too late the gas gets to her and she
collapses so young Nam has to hold his
breath and carry her inside the sister
somehow survives but she is choking
badly and her entire body is covered
with source and rashes some of the
family members try calling for an
ambulance but they are informed that at
this point only helicopters are
functional while everyone goes into a
state of panic young Nam and weiju peek
through the glass window and witness the
entire city covered in thick gas they
don't know what it is or where it came
from but what they do know is that the
gas is rising so they have to reach a
higher altitude as fast as they can
yangnam immediately approaches the
others and informs them that they have
to reach the Terrace they then make a
makeshift stretch catcher for his
injured sister and carry her upstairs
unfortunately when they reached the top
they learned that the door is locked the
only key to it is kept in the reception
on the ground floor but since that floor
has already been covered with the
poisonous gas they will have to find
another way shortly after we Jew manager
goo and a few others scavenge for
supplies on the floor below them there
the TV is functional and a news channel
is reporting about the mysterious gas
while the cause of it is still unknown
there are precautions to avoid exposure
to it the reporter states that one can
use a gas mask which will give them
about 15 minutes of immunity if they
breathe slowly it is also essential to
cover the entire body to avoid blisters
and rashes after a while three gas masks
are found and manager goo wants someone
to use them and retrieve the key from
downstairs however no one wants to risk
their lives hence with time running out
yangnam thinks of another plan he learns
that the door to the Terrace can be
opened from the outside because yangnam
is extremely gifted in athletics and
climbing he sides to risk it all in the
next scene he breaks a glass panel by
throwing objects at it then he ties a
safety rope around him turns to the
camera and says not the ex-han this is
for you he takes a flying leap of faith
despite his family pleading with him to
not do so fortunately yangna manages to
grab hold of a latch and reach the
opposite building seeing his
determination Ouija throws him some
chalk powder and a carabiner so that he
can climb more smoothly soon young Nam
starts jumping from roof to roof like
the Prince of Persia himself all the
while his cousin live streams him on his
phone so that his family can see what's
happening meanwhile young Nam reaches a
spot where he cannot grab onto the next
ledge this is because the Rope around
him is holding him back so he unhooks
the Rope meaning that he is now on his
own if he slips that will be it despite
the dire circumstance yangnam slowly
keeps on climbing he finally reaches the
last stage where all he has to do is
Propel himself upwards and grab a lion
head statue at first it it appears as if
he's going to slip but then yangnam uses
every ounce of strength in his body and
finally pulls himself up now he is on
the roof of the cloud Garden after
resting for a few seconds he gets up and
opens the door finally allowing his
family in following this the family
tries their best to attract the
attention of a nearby helicopter but to
no avail just then weju comes up with an
idea she suggests that everyone form an
h and tap their phones to give an SOS
signal they also start sounding Out the
SOS pattern to themselves
don't forget and all I can think about
was this scene from The Cable Guy
[Music]
meanwhile the perpetrator who is
responsible for all this chaos is
finally exposed it turns out that he is
the co-founder of a large biotechnology
company he was also the head scientist
but one day the other shareholders
abruptly kicked him out because of this
the man went insane and started devising
a plan to hurt the city after many
trials he ended up with this poisonous
gas as of now he is believed to be dead
because of the same gas he exposed to
the city back at the roof the family has
been tapping their phones for several
minutes but the chopper still doesn't
notice them this makes Ouija realize
that the lights in their mobile phones
are simply too tiny to be noticed hence
she goes down one floor and flickers the
large Advertising Signs of the hotel the
plan works and the Chopper's attention
is finally drawn after a while help
arrives and all the family members are
loaded into a carrier one by one however
when it's the turn of yangnam and Ouija
an alarm starts blaring indicating that
they have crossed the weight limit
because of this the two are forced to
stay back and wait for the next Chopper
to arrive but since the gas is
approaching them at an alarming rate
young Nam and Ouija decide to escape at
first they gather the three gas masks
they found earlier and then stalk as
much rope as they can in their bags
following this they cover their entire
body with plastic bags and head to the
streets in search of a safe place after
a bit of wandering around they climb to
the roof of a building only to realize
that the gas has already reached there
panicked the two rushed back to the
streets and finally reach a building
which is still safe from the gas it
turns out to be a gym with lots of
equipment in it yangnam and weiju throw
away their damaged masks drink some
water and then get ready for their next
plan since the building opposite to them
is too far to jump they will have to go
there by rope soon the two connect some
dumbbells to the ropes and launch them
across to the next building once they
feel that it is firm and safe Ouija
decides to go first owing to her lighter
weight the task is a challenging one but
Ouija is a former climbing Champion so
she crosses over to the next building
without much fuss when it is Young nam's
turn however the smoke slowly starts
reaching them time is running out and
death seems imminent but yangnam uses
the last bit of his strength and somehow
makes it a cross meanwhile the officials
learn that water has the ability to
dissipate the harmful smoke they
immediately start working on it but
eradicating the entire thing will take
some days on the other hand yangnam's
anxious father Jiang Soo reaches a safe
place where he finds two reporters using
a drone to cover the news realizing that
this may be the only way to find his son
he pays them a handsome amount and asks
them to inspect the area near Cloud
Garden elsewhere yangnam and Ouija reach
a new building where several cutouts of
humans are present suddenly they notice
a bunch of kids trapped in a nearby
building pleading for help they seem
helpless as all the doors around them
are closed so the couple decides to help
them first they use the cutouts and even
themselves to make a large arrow that
points towards the trapped children
luckily the plan works its Shopper
notices the children and rescues them
since the building appears to be tall
and safe yangnam and weiju decide to
wait for the next Chopper but just then
a nearby gas station explodes this hurls
the poisonous gas back in their
Direction compelling them to flee again
Ouija notices a large crane Tower nearby
and she suggests climbing it yangnam
doesn't like the idea but since he
doesn't have a better one he agrees in
the next scene the duo is again on the
Move surprisingly the Drone that Zhang
TSU had hired binds them it follows them
everywhere they go and even live
telecasts them with this the entire
country watches the daring escape with
excitement everybody lods their bravery
and Valor just look at all these useless
streamers pretending they have something
to do with it young nam's mom also
observes him jumping from building to
building and almost has a heart attack
meanwhile the duo reaches a tall
building which is the last one near the
crane Tower the unfortunate thing is
that the gap between them is too much
now with the poisonous gas approaching
them at a rapid rate death seems
imminent they even hug each other and
bid their final goodbyes they cry which
they do a lot in this movie but right
then a buzzing sound disturbs them it is
a swarm of drones that has arrived to
their rescue tens of thousands of
dollars worth of the damn things doing
something helpful for the first time
since their owners got them it turns out
that after witnessing their daring
escape on television many citizens
across the city have decided to help
this gives young Nam renewed hope so he
comes up with a plan he instructs one of
the drones to hook his rope on the
opposite building's pipe after this the
two tie themselves with the other end of
the rope and attempt to swing to the
large Tower the plan fails miserably and
they end up hanging in the middle of
nowhere to make matters worse the Rope
attached to the pipe also starts to
loosen this forces Ouija to come up with
an Abrupt decision so she grabs pliers
and cuts one end of the Rope the plan is
to swing to the next building but
unfortunately the Rope on the other end
disconnects as the entire country
watches on the two plummet into the
Thick Smoke seemingly to their death
everyone who is watching their dream is
left in utter shock yangnam's parents
are devastated and they cannot stop
crying even the rescue helicopter turns
back preparing to leave but right then
the pilot notices a small flare being
led on the crane tower on a closer
inspection he sees that young Nam and
Ouija are still alive they somehow made
it to the Tower and are hanging on for
dear life we do screams here and it made
me laugh really hard
in the final scene the two are rescued
and brought back to safety where young
Nam finally reunites with his parents as
usual they berate him for being Reckless
but they are also proud of The Bravery
he showcased yangnam even gets to give
his mom a piggyback just like he wanted
at the party meanwhile Ouija is alone
when manager goo comes near her and
tries to flirt with her again this time
she teaches him a lesson by punching him
hard right in the face get bent goo in
the final scene yangnam approaches Ouija
and returns her Carabiner but she
insists he give it the next time they
meet yangnam Just Smiles as he realizes
that she is interested in him the movie
ends as Mother Nature helps heal the
City by unleashing a massive rainfall
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching